حاربهم بعقابهم ما زال الاوروبيون اوفياء
لنهج انتهى الى فرض تسع حزم عقوبات على
روسيا وثم تعاشره تقترحها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه مع اقتراب ذكرى السنويه الاولى
للحرب في اوكرانيا
اليوم نزيد الضغط بحزمه مكثفه من العقوبات
نقترح مزيدا من الحظر على التصدير بقيمه
تزيد عن 11 مليار يورو لحرمان الاقتصاد
الروسي من التكنولوجيا الحيويه والسلع
الصناعيه سنقيد بشكل اكبر تصدير السلع ذات
الاستخدام المزدوج والسلع التقنيه
المتقدمه لا يرى الروس في العقوبات
الغربيه سوى جزء مما يسمونها حربا هاجينه
معلنه عليهم لكن موسكو على قناعه كما يبدو
بان شيئا ما في العالم قد تغير
يقول وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان بلاله ستركز
في سياستها الخارجيه الجديده على انهاء ما
وصفه باحتكار الغرب لشؤون دوليه وصولا الى
عالم متعدد الاقطاب
لا يوضح ما اذا كانت الحرب مع اوكرانيا
مقدمه في الفهم الروسي لاعاده صياغه
التوازنات الدوليه
لكن قبل ذلك كله من الاقرب الى الحسم في
الميدان يبدو الوضع مقلقا للغايه باعتراف
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي فكيف كما ينبه جوسيب بوريل لا
تتمتع لاول مره باسبقيه في عدد الجنود على
الارض الي يحتم هذا الواقع على حلفاء
اوكرانيا الغربيين تنسيق دعم عسكري اكبر
للاوكرانيين
تم تاكيد ارسال المزيد من انظمه الدفاع
الجوي من قبل الشركاء ومزيد من الدبابات
والمدفعيه والقذائف ومزيد من عمليات
التدريب لجيشنا لا يمكن الابلاغ عن كل شيء
بشان رمشتاين علنا يجب ترك جزء كبير من
الاتفاقات خلف الابواب المغلقه لن تخفي
تلك الابواب الانزعاج الاوكراني من تاخر
وصول ما جرى التعهد به من اسلحه هجوميه
نوعيه فالمانيا مثلا تقر بان هدفها الخاص
بتوف
القتاليه لاوكرانيا لم يتحقق حتى الان
وبينما ضبط الناتو المواعيد النهائيه
لتوليد المعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا تتزايد
مخاوف داخل الحلف من نفاد مخزونات الاسلحه
والذخيره في الدول الغربيه المشكله الاكبر
ان يتزامن ذلك مع توقع تلك الدول استعداد
الروس لجولات حرب جديده